dairy was it Fallon they got a pretty
nice spread in the dressing room with
Fallon show they got a pretty big budget
and I see this big thing at chocolate
they gave me I took it I handed it over
to Gary
I heard you ate a fair amount of it too
that's how I pay my payment chocolate
well I'm sure he appreciated he liked it
big smile on his face what's this note
Gary was talking to Jimmy Fallon when I
handed him the chocolate Gary Jimmy
Fallon was out there with you he goes to
every dressing room just talk to every
person so he was in the hallway you were
talking to him when I handed you the
chocolate I was standing in the hallway
he made his way down and as I came out
and gave you the chocolate you were with
Jimmy Fallon I'm asking a question
remember that oh I'm just asking he was
so mesmerized by the Chuck he doesn't
remember if Jimmy was there or not
wow that's weird that Gary doesn't know
Gary yeah I know Jimmy was talking to
him I don't remember
I mean that seems to me like a major
thing like your boss comes out no I'm
saying your boss comes out and hands you
chocolate and you're talking to Jimmy
Fallon you think you remember that don't
you think you'd remember that I think so
and like he you think the whole office
was out there like he was embarrassed a
bit and he doesn't remember Jimmy was a
part of it Gary it's not about you being
a dick Gary was in a chocolate coma I
think yeah I know I don't know I don't
know what's going on with you you don't
know when you were talking that you
don't think it would register with you
that I walked out of my dressing room to
hand you the big box of chocolates and
you were in the middle of a conversation
with Jimmy Fallon
Gary will says you were and that's
probably true I just say don't remember
but how do I know I mean
ooh am i so annoyed she's like a drunk
in a blackout I'm telling you he's my
ride everybody disappeared except that
basketball